for the last several years over 2,000
professors practitioners and students
from around the world descend upon New
Haven Connecticut and the Yale campus
they're here to attend the world's
leading and largest global health and
innovation conference organized by unite
foresight social entrepreneurs come to
pitch their ideas dr. Jeffrey Sachs of
the Earth Institute Seth Goldman of
honesty and dr. Betsy Bradley of the
Yale Global Health Initiative are
usually some of the 300 speakers whose
net lectures and workshops at the
conference but unite foresight is more
than just a conference it's an esteemed
global nonprofit organization that has
provided I care for more than 1.5
million patients including more than
60,000 sight restoring surgeries and
it's the brainchild of a young Yale
alumna named Jennifer staple Clark and I
got a chance to sit down with her to see
how it all got started so we're here in
Timothy Dwight College I guess this is
where it all got started then yes 13
years ago back in 2000 that's amazing so
take us to the entryway when you were
here as a student I was an entry ID
right here oh wow so this this is the
Jennifer staple Clark and true I like
that so when you were here and thinking
about getting unite for site started I
mean how did you fit that in with all of
the work that you are doing as a student
well I it started it as a small student
organization and recruited about 35
students so we actually went to the
downtown evening soup kitchen which is
right next door to TD and the New Haven
free public library which is just two
blocks down and worked with a lot of
community members to connect them with
free health coverage programs so that
they could receive a complete eye exam
by an eye doctor and then ultimately
have been able to provide care to other
communities within North America and
then also eventually internationally as
well so it sounds like the city of New
Haven really gave you a base to help
create your framework for developing
unite foresight were there other people
or mentors along the way who really gave
you some great advice and helping you to
think through the next steps for unite
foresight
yes well as I was developing unite
foresight here with in New Haven I had
some wonderful professors especially in
the anthropology department who were
very very supportive as I was developing
just as a student organization
so were there any surprises when he
first developed unite for cider as it
expanded a lot over the years I was
really very surprised at how quickly it
grew we had about 25 chapters within
North American universities within a few
months thinking back to what I had
initially planned and developed it
wasn't quite to the scale that I had
envisioned at the time so we're here in
the headquarters of unite foresight and
it looks like I can actually see where
it all got started
DNA's right out the window yes DeeDee is
right there so all of the activity going
on in the office is around the 10th
anniversary of the global health and
innovation conference that is presented
annually by an unite for site which is
very exciting so how did the whole
conference get started we had developed
the idea for a conference to exchange
ideas across all disciplines of global
health and international development and
social entrepreneurship so we started
our first conference back in 2004 and we
had about a hundred participants and
just about 5 speakers was a single day
and the conference quickly grew from
there now we have more than 2200
participants from all 50 states and 50
countries who come to New Haven each
year to attend the annual conference
well unite for sight has done so many
amazing things and I know that you have
a lot of experience with growing this
organization from the ground up what
kind of advice would you give to people
who really want to make a positive
impact on global health I think it's so
important to follow minds passion and
ideas and if you have an idea really
follow through with it and also work
with local health care professionals and
see how best you can support and assist
their work to reach patients who would
otherwise not be able to access or or
care
you